[inaudible]
I'm sure by now all of you have seen
the New York Times article on the
intellectual dark web that ran last week.
The article was a heavy lift trying to
define something that had been previously
undefined,
but it was a solid foray
into the mainstream for this
eclectic group of people.
But the record,
I believe the intellectual dark web is a
diverse group of thinkers, interviewers,
Comedians,
and academics who've been thrust together
due to the intellectual curiosity or
desire for truth and an absolute respect
for our audience's ability to make up
their minds for themselves.
There's an old Groucho Marx line.
I wouldn't want to belong to a club
that would have me as a member at first.
That was how I felt about
this intellectual dark web.
We've had a pretty great thing going
around this loosely associated group of
free thinkers, so why muck it
up with something more formal?
What I've come to see though
is that this alliance,
whether we have membership
cards in a clubhouse or not,
is now one of the most important
forces for reason that exists.
This crew of people from Harris to the
Weinstein brothers and from Shapiro to
summers have all come from different
walks of life and from different academic
and career backgrounds.
What I believe to be the one unifier in
this group is that we haven't been going
for easy answers to tough questions,
which make great soundbites but
offer little real world value.
We've all tried with success and sometimes
with failure to communicate ideas
that the mainstream media has either
ignored or misrepresented because they
often go against mainstream orthodoxy.
For example,
Sam Harris has tried to make a clear
distinction between ideas and people and
why we must be able to criticize ideas
such as Islam without becoming bigoted
towards Muslim people.
Progressive.
Bret Weinstein has tried to
show a progressive university
that fighting racism
through racist acts,
in this case,
a day of absence at school for White
people was actually itself racist.
Ben Shapiro has brought basic ideas of
conservatism to a younger generation that
is being indoctrinated
with postmodern viewpoints.
Christina Hoff Sommers has tried to show
people that the original intention of
feminism,
a true equality for women has morphed
into something about authoritarianism
rather than a quality.
All of these conversations are
important ones to have because without
conversation on these important issues,
the only option left is violence.
It doesn't mean that you have to agree
with anyone or everyone in this group of
people and they themselves disagree
on many issues with each other,
but the failure of the mainstream to
honestly and maturely talk about these
topics is exactly what drove so many
of you guys to us in the first place.
Contrary to many of the think pieces
written after the original New York Times
piece,
none of us,
none of us in this dark web
view ourselves as victims.
Actually it's the total reverse. We
were empowered by our ideas, in my case,
the belief and the individual and want
you to be empowered to fight for what you
believe in as well even
when you disagree with us.
I do want to address a few questions
related to my role in all this discussion
as well as how I view myself
and the Rubin report is a show.
One of the criticisms by Barry Weiss and
the times article was in essence about
the gatekeeping responsibility that she
feels the members of the intellectual
dark web should have.
So where are the lines we draw as to who
we talk to and what are ideas which we
won't touch.
If a conversation we're having could
lead you down a rabbit hole of unsavory
people.
Is it incumbent on us to guard you against
this journey or is it on you as the
viewer to decide what ideas in which
people cause you to draw your online?
I think you know my position on this,
but I'll say it again.
I as an individual make the choices which
I think are intellectually honest and
then I believe that it is on you,
the viewer as an individual to decide
which people and ideas you like or dislike
and then follow up on these
people and ideas yourself.
I've always felt this was the right
way to look at being an interviewer,
but I know that not everyone
agrees with this premise,
including some people I like and respect.
I also have said many times before
along the way of making these decisions,
I may make mistakes, but I'll always
try to do what I think is right.
There's also an interesting guilt by
association situation developing here.
My friend and mentor, Larry King,
the true king of interviewing,
could spend a week in 1994 interviewing
David Duke, Louis Farah can,
the cast of Seinfeld,
Michael Jordan and Frank Sinatra.
Nobody in their right mind ever felt
that that meant he was friends with or
endorsed all of these people's views.
Somehow,
and maybe this is just partly because
of Youtube and social media these days,
if we even talked to someone,
a certain segment of people think that
this automatically means you stand by
everything they've said and done.
I view this as patently absurd
and actually quite dangerous.
We have to be willing to push the sensible
boundaries of people were willing to
talk to.
Otherwise we're just talking to ourselves
and thus furthering the echo chamber
mentality that mainstream media fosters.
This brings me to a couple of people
who I've had conversations with.
I seem to get the most guff from having
to specific people on the Ruben report
as well as one interview I
did outside of this show,
I had Mike Cernovich on the Ruben report
in March of 2016 right when the Trump
phenomenon was first breaking through.
At the time,
I saw a lot of support online for Trump,
but I couldn't find any mainstream
people willing to talk about it.
Cernovich was one of the few vocal
supporters of Trump was a published author
and was catching fire on Twitter.
My conversation with Mike was totally
civil and actually quite interesting to me
as I hadn't heard anyone
articulate sensible support
for Trump before that point.
As the next two years unfolded,
Cernovich was a central figure in
conspiracy theories such as pizza gate,
while also being at the front
of Hillary's health issues,
which the media ignored until she passed
out in front of her SUV on that fall
day in New York City in 2016 and
let's not forget the Donna Brazil,
the former head of the DNC,
actually confirmed Cernovich's reporting
when she said that the DNC was thinking
about replacing Hillary at
one point during the campaign.
I didn't know about some of
Mike's distasteful blog posts,
which were written before I sat down
with him and I certainly can't be held
accountable for what anyone does
after they've been on the show.
What I can be held accountable for is
the way I conduct myself in an interview
with a controversial person,
which thus far I'm absolutely proud of.
One of the reasons I wasn't surprised
by the election of Donald Trump was
because that very conversation that I
had with Cernovich led me to believe it
was going to be a possibility.
So while mainstream media ignored figures
which were deemed deplorable and felt
that Hillary was a shoe in,
I dared have the conversations which
allowed me and hopefully you to see the
future more clearly.
The other interview,
which people were upset by was
my chat with Stefan Molyneux.
Stefan is heavily focused on race and Iq,
which is not a discussion on a pro at nor
one that I care to focus on that much.
Actually, I asked him this very
question during the interview,
what is it about race and Iq that you
feel the need to talk about it so much?
His answer in essence was that he
talks about it because he finds it so
troubling.
His answer is for you,
the viewer to either accept or reject.
Perhaps I could have poked
or prodded in another way,
but I felt trying to figure out why he
thinks as he does is what my job is.
The other important one to address here
is an interview that I did on the Alex
Jones show back in February of last year.
This was right after my
why I left the left video,
came out from Prager university and I
was getting a ton of press requests that
week. I also did Tucker Carlson on Fox
News and would've been just as happy to do
MSNBC or CNN had. They
invited me. My feelings,
as I've said in a bunch of live stream
since was that if I went on Jones his
show and it was aired live and unedited,
I might be able to bring my message of
conversation and classical liberalism to
Jones,
his audience.
I know it worked by the way because I've
received dozens of messages from Jones,
his fans who said how nice it was to hear
a different perspective and since then
they've been challenged by other
interviews that we do right here.
The criticism of course is that I somehow
legitimize Jones by doing his show in
the first place.
I don't see it that way myself,
but I'm sympathetic to the argument and
as Uncle Ben said to Peter Parker with
great power comes great responsibility.
I didn't think that a year
ago I had great power,
but as things have ramped up around here,
it appears that I do these days.
I should also remind you that there are
plenty of people who wouldn't want me to
sit down with Jordan Peterson because
they say he's all right or Sam Harris
because they say he's anti
Muslim charges that I,
and you know absolutely to not be true.
This is the dangerous place we're all in
when we all act like the gatekeepers of
others' capacity to make decisions
for themselves. With all this in mind,
I'd like to offer up three Ruben
report rules going forward. One,
I will keep the focus more
on ideas that on people.
This won't always be totally possible,
but I'll always do my best to honor that
principle to I'll continue to interview
potentially controversial people,
but will increase my efforts to shed
light on ideas that they have that I'm
concerned or unsavory.
I'll give them a chance to explain
themselves as I believe that sunlight,
of course, is the best disinfectant.
If I'm cordial to someone,
it doesn't mean that I endorse them.
I think we're in serious
danger of eliminating
conversations that are necessary
to understanding the big picture because
some of us may feel compromised by
simply listening.
Trump's election and Brexit were only
surprises if you turned up your nose to
listening to half the electorate.
Three,
I'll keep trying to build bridges in some
places where others would reflectively
burn them down.
This is always tricky because I naturally
don't want to legitimize bad actors,
but I'll always try to see if there's
room to make inroads with someone where I
may have been trained to think
that they were my sworn enemy.
My bridges won't be built everywhere,
though.
We've got to have some standards of
decency to make sure that the idea is we
want to build upon here are in sitting
on a mountain of quicksand as what we do
here.
It gets put more into the spotlight.
I have more of a responsibility to live
up to the ideals that I've laid out here.
I'm never gonna make everyone happy
and it's why at the end of the day,
I can only answer to my own conscience.
I believe that we are starting
to win in the public square,
and this will now bring all
sorts of new people our way.
2018 is undoubtedly the
year of unusual alliances.
The invites have been sent out, so now
let's see who shows up to the party.